and good evening to you thank you for
joining us at five i'm brian loftis i'm
denise valdez an attempted bank robbery
caused a major scene near downtown las
vegas today police swarmed at charleston
and las vegas boulevard this afternoon
trying to arrest the suspect victoria
saha they're now joining us with the
very latest
this wells fargo is in the middle of a
very busy area close to downtown it was
closed off for a very long time until
recently the crime tape came down but
i'm going to have my photog zoom in over
there the cardboard board was just put
up recently no one is allowed into that
bank you can see security is standing
right in front making sure no customers
walk in
details are very limited but police say
they received a call just after 12 this
afternoon about a robbery at a bank
police say there was no mention of a
weapon but without giving detailed
information police say the teller
assumed a robbery was unfolding based on
the suspect who walked in and police are
confirming it was a robbery as soon as
officers got on scene they say employees
and customers were leaving the building
but the suspect was still inside they
were able to set up around the building
and get information from those who were
still inside on what was happening swat
was called
upon their arrival they took the suspect
into custody without incident the area
by charleston and las vegas boulevard
was closed down no one was allowed near
the area on foot or by car i had bought
a woman in a wheelchair the wrong flavor
of this and when i came back to
exchange it police across the street
told us to go back we weren't allowed to
be in this area he worried a lot of
people police did a fabulous job
no one was hurt during this attempted
robbery police are still investigating
and again if this is the wells fargo you
go to just remember it is closed for the
rest of the day reporting near
charleston and las vegas boulevard
victoria saha live local now